it's directed by michael grandage yes
and you were saying that Michael perhaps
thought of you because of poles are yeah
but Michael lives he's he's from
Cornwall and obviously Poldark did the
show I mean is shot there it's set there
so yeah and I don't have you been to
Cornwall but I mean my face is kind of
everywhere isn't it sits on mugs and
it's on dish cloths a lot of things I
just think I was in his psyche all the
time
the meat he was quite random you know I
don't know why he called me but I just
think I was there you know he was just
drying the dishes thing is you know
obviously people love pulled up
merchandise but not everyone wants to
buy it
some people make their own okay now
where is where's Angela oh there's
Angela
where do you live Angela in Suffolk
inside okay and Angela oh she loves to
knit but she has gone she has gone but
Poldark crazy
that's use me that she anything
[Applause]
yeah yeah
your lovin house that you might be
looking at these and thinking yeah
they're cute but I'm not sure if they
capture the raw sexual energy of Boulder
oh they do
do not hit some grass you don't you've
done I mean you've done all the carrot
they're all in here this so did you just
knit Poldark no I've got lots of others
but pull docks my main one yes is the
dog from Poldark
yeah I'm told MA oh yes is that me
yes oh thank you so much these must go
back to the Poldark knitting Museum
obviously it's very special because
apparently this is this is from series 4
this is your outfit from series 4 this
is the fourth is coming out on the 10th
of June
yes this is yet to be seen no good this
is you live started doing the trails
which look of aid and this is the air
isn't that right I think so yes watch
the show herself
[Applause]
[Music]